[Musique]
ouais à la vôtre est la parfaite mais le
recul est allé bon anniversaire à
l'évidence bluesy bercy
c'est ma prestation de adel someone like
you sata plus petits un petit peu son
premier habitat en fait t'es là que pour
ça quoi eux c'est scandaleux on fête un
anniversaire l'été la champomy c'était
sur quoi tu étais sur un bon nom mais
aucun vite un anniversaire que son
anniversaire un petit verre de champomy
pour toi aussi tu cherches offre une
fleur aux merci c'est très aimable il
fait péter le gâteau ou par un gâteau
ouais tu veux quoi comme cadeau j'ai
uniquement du champomy toumba et ben
c'est pas il ya dix ans le vert qui
savait parce qu'en fait je sais j'en
sert à tout le monde mais du coup ils
vous ne pouvez pas le boire
malheureusement donc du coup il ya plein
[Musique]
air bon bah c'est beaucoup c'est l'anti
rien cette coupe de cul
1 2 3 j ai raté faut la refaire merde
ouais respire cette fumée toxique qui
donne de graves maladies ou bon waouh
ciao annonçant germaine je bouffais
rencontre on fait plutôt cher voilà qu
alain de chat merci pour tout ouais
[Applaudissements]
4 abonnés là ont fait 4 abonnés en fait
si choqué toi tu souffres même s'ils
étaient choqués tu fais un souffle aux
chocs et aux attentes assez lucide et
non c'est pas vu ça mélanie nom ne dit
pas mathilde assez gris annoncé assez
infects ouais bon bah bientôt qu'est
cette femme sur le poster derrière toi
c'était à taylor swift
attends je te fais une petite poire et
cana est ce que ça t'a plu à trois
défaites attendues en hausse également
pas lui mais tu as fait une apparition
de l'espace quoi oui ouais pour moi j'ai
payé tes parents non ah merde je pensais
à bientôt et merci bon anniversaire à
tous ce coup-ci barrieu la danse pas moi
[ __ ] c'est un monogramme ce soit quand
même tu vas pas les reflets bleus non
c'est vraiment trop bah non je te dis je
suis un hologramme tu vois pas les
reflets bleus a tangué ruines non
messieurs au programme un hologramme ne
ment jamais dit tu es toujours qu'il est
un hologramme en [ __ ] je laisse tomber
sur ce quiz n'est pas possible
plus les journées longues mais comme je
suis un vrai mais c'est le jour mon
anniversaire
ouais c'est la cerda mines on lui
souhaite tous un joyeux anniversaire
3 2 a du souffle oui pour habib achour
le faire georges braque un boguey mais
ça fait pleurer des yeux ouais
ouais c'est la fête à dabou j'aime le
cameroun [ __ ] c'est mon casque équipe
aigles à la jetant à ok bah je t'entends
pas là pardon excusez moi j'arrête pas
de souffre et de plus de 8 cette vidéo
j'en veux plus mais papa tu sais pas
vous oui bah tu veux je me suis tout de
suite on fait comment 3 2 1
ouais ah j'ai rencontré un tweet salut
le sweat comment ça va 2 1 j'ai rien
sauf les belles toiles ah ah bah oui
faut se réveiller
toi aussi tu m'as fait un petit mot pas
de micros on t'adore
meba ce site un micro je l'attend en
imposteur merci je vois les
anniversaires d'accord de marseille nice
marseille et suit marseille et le
champomy ouais ouais tu permets de
seconde qui permet bien sûr et oui les
objections de 8 en asie
vas-y pour lui ça va quoi comment vas tu
on dit merci grand frère non c'est faux
vous remercie tous nos frères pas contre
les rebelles image la vérité dans un
film sérieux quoi c'est ce que dit non
non hahahaha
toi aussi ça mais juste un max de temps
à s'allumer ah bah écoute c'est pas
joyeux anniversaire c'était une vidéo
ben regarde bien sûr cette vidéo bien
sûr que cette vidéo on regarde bien sûr
cette vidéo a bien sûr c'est une vidéo
bas bien sûr cette vidéo bon avantage
préfère georges était une vidéo ça va
marcher au talent unique rossato le plus
de la planète
je sais pas si on est dans un lave linge
ou alors on est en enfer que ça pète
salon faire non pas la main comment tu
vas ah non mais il faut répondre
attention moi je vais même pas cher
quand même encore bah oui c'est vraiment
moi je veux tu que ce soit bah oui bah
moi si tu sol t'inquiète pas mais ça me
fait plaisir aussi au [ __ ] ça mais qui
est encore violet ça donc il veut danser
avec moi je sais pas mais non mais non
mais non mais non sérieux banon passé à
iasi plus de répartie pour sa part alain
le gall abidjan je t'ai vu tu te mordre
les onglets j'étais comme ça chez tattoo
donoma l'attenté c'est pas de berne est
là tout hasard si je te dis ah bon
anniversaire sans trucage aux saluts
monsieur sinon je vois tu habites un
monsieur qui coûtera la tension croît
alors par contre le son dans lequel on
restait serpillière de ce n'est pas sur
la tête ces points chauds au soudan se
sont mêlés sapir ce chapeau de chopper
là je t'entends aux attentions des
casques aux [ __ ] attends je prends
une photo à donges autorise pas en fait
désolé mais joyeuse anny bey ça c'est
scandaleux c'est quoi ça non mais tu te
marque de la tête au dessus du lit comme
[ __ ] tu es comme dans ce retour très
vite dans quoi dans une prochaine
il énonce est bien l aventure continue
moi je continuerai à tous de suivre les
basques bientôt dans les prochaines
vidéos alors votre continuation de la
scie à métaux
[Musique]